[موسيقى]
لم تبدا الصحف الغربيه منذ ان اطلق الامير
هاري فوضى تسريبات التي رافقت طرحها كتابه
الذي يحكي قصه حياته المطربه مع العائله
الملكه وانفصاله عنها
الاعلام الغربي
كيفيه ترميم العلاقه بين
هاري وشقيقه
وفق علماء النفس ان في بعض الاحيان يكون
الابتعاد عن العلاقه مع الاخ او انهائها
صعبا او مخجلا لكن بعد القطيعه يشعر الشخص
بتحسن اما الامر الذي ادى الى القطيعه بين
الاميرين الشقيقين بحسب علماء النفس فهو
ربما تكون المنافسه بينهما او التمييز من
قبل العائله في يشعر احد الاشقاء بانه اقل
قيمه
واشنطن بوست اعتبرت ان الهجوم الشامله ضد
قصر باكينغهام من قبلها ريكان للترويج
لكتابه الجديد المكون من 400 صفحه في حين
تقول صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه ان كتاب
ذو قيساكس الامير هاري هو الاكثر اثاره
وجدلا في كتب السير الذاتيه الملكيه وان
النجله الثاني للملكه تشارلز روى تفاصيل
المواجهه بين عائلته من دون ان تاخذ طرفا
بين الجانبين
الفرنسيه فكانت اكثر تشددا مع هاري وميجا
وكتبت بالعنوان العريض انه رغم كلامهما
واحلامهما لم يتمكنا من تحرير نفسه ماء
ووصفه الاميره الباحثه عن الحريه بالمهوس
محاسن حضاره العربيه